purchased a home at 27 um however I lost
my job after 10 years and I sold my
condo in 2016 I live at home I'm now 42
and I created a lot of debt for myself
but I want to purchase a condo in 2025
so I just wanted your advice and a
strategy of on how what what debt to pay
down first um I have $110,000 in total
debt um three personal loans three
credit cards and I have
$45,000 student loan debt I'm still in
school seeking my masters and I'll be
done at the end of the year so I'm not
currently paying that right now I have $
36,4 and20 my 401k I I know I borrowed
from my 401k um $20,000 to pay off my
debt which I accured again um so right
now by weekly I'm paying 17194 at 4.5%
interest on my 401k Nia you need to pay
off
$70,000 say save up a down save up an
emergency fund then save up a down
payment